gì cả Tôi định chia sẻ về cái
có một bài đăng bài đăng kiểu về
kiểu tết offline dịch ra thì sẽ có thể
hiểu là kiểu là la leo đã đang phát
triển đến cái ngưỡng nào ở năm 2022 Cho
dù là chưa hết năm Nhưng mà thực ra là
đã có cái
cái bài khảo sát này
mà số người lượng người tham gia thì có
phải khá là ít hơn so với năm ngoái chắc
là tôi phải theo dõi cái này để tôi cập
nhật biết đâu Năm sau tôi sẽ được à Năm
sau tôi sẽ làm khảo sát xong rồi mình sẽ
không hẳn là được nhắc tên ông này nhưng
mình đóng góp một phần nào đó và cái hay
của cái của cái của cái trang này tôi
thấy hôm nay tôi đặt thì nó là ngoài
việc Ừ mình theo Ariel thì mình biết
được là những cái người cùng làm cùng
theo mình đúng không ạ
Họ giới tính là gì họ tập trung ở đâu đã
có bao nhiêu năm kinh nghiệm xong rồi họ
vẫn vân vân dùng dùng cái gì Ví dụ Giả
sử là dùng hệ điều hành Mac nhiều hơn
Windows này xong rồi dùng à cái code
Editor nào nhiều nhất thì pps stone này
nó nhiều hơn so với scode
[âm nhạc]
ngôn ngữ thử ngôn ngữ lập trình khác mà
họ dùng thì ra Switch chẳng hạn thế đông
nhất đông nhất đấy chẳng hạn thế bởi vì
à về bản chất thì cái này thì nó dễ hiểu
vì mình có ngôn ngữ bác em rồi thì fan
en mình nên dùng rascript để mà kiểu
hiển thị lên thôi Chứ thường là ít ai
rồi Học xong xong hai ngôn ngữ lập trình
Cùng lúc
đấy thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là không không
phải mỗi
chúng ta không phải mỗi chúng ta là học
mỗi pp thôi cái này multible cho đấy nhé
là có thể chọn song song nhiều thứ cùng
lúc nhưng mà rõ ràng là đương nhiên là
cũng có một ít số người nào đó vẫn học
vẫn học kiểu ngôn ngữ lập trình bác em
khác nhưng chủ yếu là họ học ra clip để
xử lý Ford là đủ rồi bác and lauriel là
đủ rồi đấy không đến nỗi kiểu dạng là
mình phải học thêm nhiều ngôn ngữ lập
trình làm gì cả tiếp theo là làm kiểu
theo sở thích hay kiểu
hay là có bao gồm cả kinh doanh đúng
không ạ Nhìn Nam kinh nghiệm này thì một
năm năm vẫn là đông nhất nghĩa là tiềm
năng vẫn nhiều À không không Đây là tim
sai
pp phiên bản bao nhiêu này
255 kinh nghiệm vẫn là nhiều nhất này
kiểu thế nhưng mà ngoài ra ngoài việc là
các bạn có thể đọc thêm ở link này nhé
Nhưng cái tôi thấy hay ở đây đó là những
cái những cái mà họ thích rất nhiều như
này này thì thì
thì không nói gì đôi khi ở những cái mà
bạn biết rồi nhưng có những cái mà bạn
còn chưa biết Giả sử Thế ví dụ ra Violet
là gì đấy chẳng hạn thế đấy thì bản chất
là nó đều hỗ trợ để mà chạy
kiểu chạy code được ở local nghĩa là tại
mà chính máy của mình hoặc tiên tương tự
Container là gì không biết này chẳng hạn
thế xong rồi cái addition này thì có thể
nhiều bạn để thỉnh thoảng mình có chạy
để cho kiểu chạy kiểu dạng nó sẽ nó tự
tạo mẹ ở trại
tiếp theo là remote là gì nhiều cái tiếp
theo là khi mà đi bốc thì sử dụng sử
dụng gì Một là dùng lệnh để máy in ra
hai dùng cái kiểu like đi Bangkok 3 mà
tôi có cài xong tele Scope là gì Chắc là
hôm nay tôi giới thiệu thua luôn Hoặc
Block Quốc là gì cha tôi cũng sẽ giới
thiệu luôn đấy tôi cài Club
thì thì đấy nghĩa là ngoài những cái mà
các bạn làm để khảo sát các bạn sẽ tham
khảo thêm xem là kiểu
người đồng nghiệp cùng chính tuyến
thì họ dùng gì để mà cậu để để mà kiểu
thì họ dùng gì để mà cẩu đây xử lý ví dụ
là các bạn còn chưa biết về khái niệm đi
Bắc cơ tôi biết rồi nhưng mà cài nó hơi
lằng nhằng ở trên cái Facebook
những cái nữa chắc chắn là có khi rất ít
bạn đã từng động vào về bản thân tôi
cũng ít đấy ví dụ là cắt tool để mà kiểm
tra xem kiểm tra xem kiểu
là đây chất lượng của cos của các bạn
như thế nào bao gồm là việc à cụ pp unis
với cả test tất cả các tùng để xem mà
cốt các bạn chạy đã ồn hay chưa có phát
sinh là lỗi gì không thay vì mình cứ
ngồi mình code xong một đoạn mình lại
test lại thủ công bằng tay hoặc test lại
rất nhiều bước các thứ mình làm đoạn cốt
để chạy từ đầu đến cuối để test để nó
phải in ra thế này phải hiển thị ra thế
này phải in ra kết quả như này Đấy được
hết tiếp theo là tiêu chuẩn của code nó
sẽ kiểm tra mình tiêu chuẩn quốc Cốt về
cơ bản thì thằng pp stone này nó khá là
tiện là nó có tích hợp thêm và hỗ trợ
tích hợp thêm những cái này để một vài
cái thôi nhé Không phải tất cả nhưng mà
để kiểm tra xem là code của mình có kiểu
dạng là có vấn đề hay không nhưng mấy
ông thấy thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ có màu ở đây
của tôi để kiểm tra xem cốt của tôi kiểu
như này Đấy là kiểu kiểm tra xem cái này
thì kiểm tra hàm không tồn tại vì nó đọc
có thể không đúng lắm nhưng nhiều lúc nó
kiểm tra Tôi ví dụ Giả sử là là kiểu nên
có nên có đóng này nên có kiểu thông báo
kết quả trả về nhé chẳng hạn đấy hay là
hay là kiểu dạng là tên
đây ví dụ kiểu như này đấy Tao đang gọi
thông qua cái thằng này không tốt phải
nên dùng cái hàm để mà gọi Gọi lấy được
thằng này chứ không phải gọi thông qua
theo kiểu là như thế này ví dụ kiểu ghét
như này lên như này thì nó sẽ chuẩn hơn
đấy chẳng hạn thế
này tôi Tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông một cái
mà chưa thấy tôi đọc rất là hay là để
kiểm tra về
sau đó thì tôi sẽ tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem
qua về mấy cái ru của nó rất là hay
liên kết
[âm nhạc]
để để chỉ mỗi riêng lin cos rue này thôi
nó đã kiểu dẫn đến rất nhiều gái khác
à Không
tất cả rồi đây
kiểu nó sẽ kiểu tránh việc gì như nào
đấy ngon tránh cả heo chỉ nên có ít thôi
hạn chế nên có ít và Return sớm đây kiểu
trả lời kết quả sớm kẻo để nó ngắt không
nhảy đến cái dưới đỡ phải dùng Eo chẳng
hạn thế hoặc là nếu mà
nếu mà có quá nhiều
kiểu phải chia cos nhiều Speed code phải
chia cos rất nhiều thì mình nên chia
thành nhiều Mỹ thớt nhỏ hơn thay vì kiểu
dạng kiểu ít eo ít eo
có thể đọc kỹ hơn ở trên trang này nếu
mà ông không hiểu tiếng Anh cho lắm thì
tôi khuyên à Ngoài việc cố đọc để hiểu
thì ông cũng nên xem luôn cả ví dụ của
nó để cho dễ dễ hình dung hơn Hãy cảm
thấy
ở đây đề cập rất nhiều nhé để cập rất
nhiều thì nó sẽ kiểm tra hết cho tất cả
mấy ông ấy
cái trang này về cơ bản thì nó sẽ
kiểu ngoài việc để mà khảo sát ra nó
cũng có một tí ở giới thiệu cho mình xem
là là kiểu đây nếu mà nó không gợi ý ra
ngoài gợi ý ra kiểu cho vui kiểu như này
rõ ràng nó gợi ý là có lý do nào cả để
cho mình biết qua việc là rất nhiều đông
đảo anh em đang dùng cái gì đấy Kiểu thế
mình có cảm thấy bị lạc loài không Khi
mà mình không dùng
mấy ông hoàn toàn hệ tham khảo được cái
này
tương tự thế thôi
trên cái kênh
chia sẻ
tài liệu thì mấy ông có thể xem qua nữa
nhé Trên đây cũng có vài cái kiểu từ
top 35
Block mà bạn nên theo dõi này hay là 15
19 cái laser ecosystem này đấy để bạn
tham khảo xem Tại sao lại nên có nó
thìa Autocad bản chất tôi tôi chưa động
đến nhưng tôi hiểu qua thì nó là kiểu nó
kiểu dạng là cốt để mà
nó cũng là lập trình và chạy trên nền
Windows à Để để kiểu tự động đương nhiên
tên nó Nó lên tất cả nhưng tự động để mà
chạy một cái gì đó thường hay viết để
làm phần mềm thì
với các bạn thì tôi thấy là nó cũng
không hẳn khó học nên học nhanh cũng
được học để làm tự động cái gì đó vui
vui
bản chất thì cái chết
không biết là không biết giải thích cho
ông kiểu như nào thì bản chất là nó cái
nó khác Thằng phương pháp nó nó kiểu
dạng là nó
class hình như vẫn kế thừa được mà nhỉ
Nhưng mà cái này bản chất chết nó sinh
ra để mà thằng khác kế thừa cái thằng
đấy giống như là giống như ở đây
cái hai hàm này code để thằng class khác
nó sẽ kế thừa cái thằng này đơn giản thế
thôi đơn giản là là sinh ra một thằng để
mà thằng tất cả những thằng class khác
nó sẽ kế thừa hoặc chết này giống như
bạn thấy ở đây là yêu để mà kế thừa thậm
chí là một hàng có thể kế thừa rất nhiều
chết để có thể dùng được rất nhiều cái
hàm của thần chết đấy mình sẽ gọi dùng
rít như này tôi gọi thằng chết như bình
thường không ạ thì đơn giản thế nếu mà
hiểu đơn giản là kiểu tạo chết là để
thằng khác kế thừa những cái hàm của nó
thế thôi còn có khái niệm thêm mà
interface với với kiểu chết nữa thì bản
chất interface ở tôi thấy là tôi tôi
đã từng gặp như tôi chưa dùng tôi chưa
dùng Internet face trong pp
và tôi thấy tuyết dễ hiểu và dễ dùng hơn
so với interface cá nhân tôi quan điểm
như thế chắc là do tôi chưa hẳn chuyên
cái hướng đối tượng lắm Dưới Face công
nhận rất phổ biến ở bên Java thì rất là
phổ biến tôi có làm gần đây nhắc đến Lập
trình hướng đối tượng thì tôi sẽ thấy là
tôi cứ tưởng tôi yếu lập trình đối tượng
nhưng mà tôi dại tôi gần như tôi đọc lại
mấy cái bài về lập trình của đối tượng
ấy hóa ra là thời gian nó cũng không
hẳn là
quá quá
kiểu dạng mình chưa động đến bao giờ hóa
ra tôi từng động rồi qua là nó bị lý
thuyết quá làm cho mình cứ tưởng mình
nói là một cái gì đó ghê gớm lắm Gà của
tôi tôi đã từng tiếp xúc và làm rồi Thế
là khi nào tôi sẽ thử làm demo cho mấy
ông tôi sẽ nói theo cách hiểu của tôi
thì để Chắc làm mấy ông sẽ cảm thấy đỡ
sợ giống như tôi
telesalesport là hai cái thứ rất nó khác
nhau Nó có ưu nhược điểm khác nhau nên
là thích thì mấy ông vẫn có thể cài Cả
hai cái này cùng một lúc không cần nhất
thiết phải kiểu bảo là em chỉ cần muốn
cài cho em cài đi bước 3 rồi em không
thích cài lại tele Scope
thì ra không Không phải thế
vừa thêm vào database được không Anh Ồ
thường thường là
Bạn có thể dùng cái hàm lắc latit thì nó
sẽ là kiểu mặc định là theo cột cho hết
được tất thì sẽ là 3 là những sản phẩm
mới nhất còn không thì có thể lấy là là
cậu theo cột ID tự động tăng Còn nếu mà
bạn không có cả hai cột đấy Chẳng có gì
chứng minh
là sản phẩm mới nhất được thêm vào cả
tuy là mình nhìn thấy hiện nó hiển thị
dưới cùng đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà là lúc
mà SQL để mà lấy ra thì tôi nghĩ là
không không có cách để lấy mình không
biết Cụ thể một cái order bài nào cả
Pocket nào để format code
anh chỉ có dùng cái để mà tự động căn
chỉnh lại anh anh có chia sẻ ở trên
Blog của anh ấy thì nói chuyện nó cũng
hẳn không format code lại cách tối ưu
hoàn toàn đâu nó chỉ hỗ trợ để căn chỉnh
lại dầu quá kiểu cắt tóc cả dấu bằng
bằng nhau thôi Nó là cái
căn chỉnh dấu bằng và và À đúng rồi đúng
rồi tôi tôi
tạo cái phím tắt là Ctrl Huyền xong rồi
dùng cái tự động của thằng street cũng
để căn chỉnh phần nào đó và thường dùng
cái căn chỉnh này nó sẽ căn chỉnh cái
thẻ hội là nhiều hơn thẻ tml là nhiều
hơn Tôi không dùng nó để căn chỉnh code
cho lắm
it thì nó là là Dũng
c 1 phân Thôi c thì đương nhiên là cơ
bản hơn
kiểu Ý tôi là nó cũng kiểu nó cũng kiểu
dạng là nó
cũng không phổ biến này và nó cũng kiểu
nói chung là chỉ làm những cái thứ cơ
bản
chữa dần sau nhé À tôi trả lời dần Sau
hôm nay thì xem là hôm nay mình sẽ
là làm đang làm đến đâu cơ
à
cái
quần xi thì phải tôi xem lại full xi
nhan
hôm trước tôi sửa lại khu vườn si
luôn suy tôn à truyền và là nun
ok chuyển vào nôn
mình sẽ trả về nó trống nhà
lỗi à
có sai sai đây rồi hôm trước là tôi test
code Ok Ok hôm trước tôi test code
trả về nó là đâu
về Nó là kiểu
cái gì đó thành ra nó bị lỗi như này để
xem nhé
thôi nó bị lỗi
anh Mạnh Tuấn làm trên đấy phải
này cúm
đề thế tội chẳng nhớ là mình đang sợ gì
cơ Ờ để xem nhé Ở đây Đúng rồi phải sửa
lại cái Thanh ở trên này này tôi nhớ là
phải thế ngoài chỉnh ngôn ngữ này mình
chỉnh mình có cái nút ở đây nhớ nút đấy
là gì nút đấy để
nhập đăng ký Tôi nghĩ là đăng nhập đi
đăng nhập
bài gì đó
mình có
sửa lại cái router ở đây đăng nhập hạn
thế
chịu với cái y này sẽ để đây sửa lại
thành à
mưa đi
lửa
trang này mình chỉ có cài
cái router là
bên này từ login thôi
tôi không để nó kiểu nhảy sang trang mới
như này
đó mà tôi sửa lại luôn cả đoạn này
bạn nhắc tôi mới nhớ sửa luôn đoạn này
nó sẽ là nhảy về đến CR router là home
nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm cái này và cái
này sẽ là
áp nêm
cũng tốt nhỉ
Thôi mình mình sẽ ở đây à
Nếu mà có đô la thay hồ thì sẽ lấy để
mình có thể hoàn toàn là khi mà nhảy vào
thay hồ như kiểu vào trong cái vào cái
cụ thể như này thì mình sẽ
vào cái cụ thể như này thì mình sẽ dùng
post rồi trâu để lấy
để lấy ra chẳng hạn
đến góc 2h
là lấy mỗi thay thôi Kiểu như này hay là
gạch ngang tên của chóp hay thổ được
nhưng mà thôi cái đoạn này dài quá rồi
cha tôi lấy luôn truyền thẳng ở đây
nhanh
văn bản để hiển thị ra cái này chắc là
tôi sẽ nhờ ông nào ngồi sửa lại cái đoạn
này sau toàn bộ cái footer hay mấy cái
dưới này rất là nhiều ông hoàng ngồi sửa
lại hoặc là khi nào tôi tôi deployd tôi
đẩy lên web thì tôi sẽ sửa lại cái này
sau còn cái gì nhỉ
anh rồi không làm đồ án chỉ học theo
trên video có ảnh hưởng gì không anh nên
làm đồ án chứ phải nên Thứ nhất là lên
làm đồ án thì mới thực sự là mình bị
hiểu được là là mình đã làm được cái
chưa chứ không phải học học bổ ích lý
thuyết rồi chưa đủ thứ hai là là làm đồ
án thì để và báo lại cho mình chẳng hạn
để mình chấm qua thì bạn sẽ hiểu được là
bạn còn thiếu những cái gì đúng không ạ
Và Cái thứ ba là bạn sẽ sẽ có kinh
nghiệm thôi và có kinh nghiệm đấy thì sẽ
khi mà đi nếu bạn muốn theo ngành nghề
này thì bạn phải đi kiểu phỏng vấn đi
thì bạn sẽ có cái thứ để mà khoe người
ta chứ mình nói mồm là đã học hết khóa
này khóa này thì
học lại học lauriel đến ngưỡng nào rồi
thì nói mồm thôi chưa đủ bắt buộc phải
nên có cái gì đó khoe người ta tốt về
khi mà ông nói xong đặc biệt khi mà nghe
kiểu phản biện Bảo bị đồ án xong
khi đi phỏng vấn ông sẽ chỉ cần nói đúng
kiểu na ná kiểu thế khi mà gặp nhà Tuyển
dụng thôi thì thì ông sẽ biết cách nói
ông sẽ tự tin hơn thì thì ông sẽ dễ
phỏng vấn qua được Nói chung là tôi thấy
theo cách dạy của tôi là khiến cho đa số
sinh viên cũng gọi đang đa số sinh viên
thôi theo được còn nên là tôi cũng khá
tự tin về vấn đề đấy
chẳng có gì đáng sợ cả anh ạ Thế tốt rồi
đúng không ạ em thế rất là tốt cậu là
mình đã khiến cho sinh viên mình rất tự
tin dám đi phỏng vấn và kiểu không sợ gì
mấy nữa
ở đây có cái kiểu cái
chưa hiểu lắm luôn
cá Thái Thùy
hôm trước sửa có gì sai sai rồi
nêm và 68
nên quả này sợ 68 nhỉ
được nêm Ok nhưng mà ra 68 thì tôi thấy
hơi buồn cười
linh ta linh vào bị như thế này
Tắt bớt đi này Xóa bớt đi
cái đoạn này hình như mình inbox vào hôm
trước là nó bị sai vì mất cái Office của
tôi rồi nên là không hiển thị toàn bộ
ngôn ngữ ở đây chắc bây giờ tôi thử Xóa
toàn bộ đi rồi tôi inbox lại xem nào
mình sang bên admin đi
tư cách bên
không là Min đi cái này hình như là lấy
ở bên cái tháp của tôi
import lại toàn bộ bài đăng này
mình
select
kiểm tra này sau đó thì tạo một
Translation này
tôi biết trong này có tạo trai sừng rất
xịn này Đấy sau đó thì mình
select kiểm tra
hiện hay chưa để xem xem lại cách xử lý
của tôi Tôi không nhớ cách xử lý lắm
không có thì sẽ để không quên đi luôn
như thế truyền truyền vào
đây sẽ có bị nhược điểm là mấy ông thấy
là nó sẽ lặp lại Nếu giả sử Company này
lặp lại hai lần thì nó sẽ là nó sẽ nó sẽ
kiểu select 2 lần 1 select Một Lần này
thì kiểm tra xong rồi tạo xong một
select nữa là select nặng cho dù rõ ràng
là mình đã select từ trước ở trong mạng
này rồi nhưng mà do là Company tôi không
chụp nhiều cho lắm nên tôi mới để bỏ qua
chứ không Thì ông nên xử lý vòng lặp
mạng như hồi trước tôi từng làm
tôi nói thế chắc là để khi nào tối ưu
hơn nữa thì tôi sẽ chỉ mấy hôm sau
mình sẽ kiểm tra xem là cũng tương tự
thế với language
Thực tế tôi muốn cho mấy ông quen với
việc dùng hàm first orc này thôi kiểm
tra xem Nó tồn tại hay không Không thì
tạo này Đấy
xong rồi liên tục là kiểm tra lại snack
bởi vì thằng thằng post này mình sẽ dùng
mình dùng cái snack Apple nên là mình sẽ
luôn kiểm tra lại là là kiểu xem là
snack lấy hợp hợp với không
nó không nhẹ đâu Tuy là tốn thời gian xử
lý nó khá là thấp thôi nhưng mà nó tốn
rất nhiều câu truy vấn vào chẳng qua là
bảng của mình đang ít dữ liệu nên thành
ra là truy vấn mọi thứ nó vẫn rất là
nhanh đấy
về tele Scope trước sau đó thì sang Club
thì tele Scope là gì
đầu tiên là ông chạy cái này xong phải
chạy Minecraft
cái này theo kiểu là Nouvo
niệm dep vừa khái niệm kiểu bình thường
bởi vì ông thích có thể đẩy cái này lên
lên dạng là kiểu dạng là xem ở trên trên
kia ông thể theo dõi được nhưng tôi nghĩ
là
theo dõi luôn cả clockwork
bảng đây Ok Ok sau đó thì mình chỉ cần
kiểm tra
cái này nếu ông muốn kiểm tra Còn không
thì mặc định sẽ là
Nó sẽ là như này web môi giới này tele
Scope
nó bởi vì mình My Wireless từ hôm trước
Hình như hôm trước cũng install rồi nên
thành ra nó sẽ có những cái đây có rất
nhiều cái ở đây và thường là tôi sẽ tắt
bớt ngay đi Vì nó có quá nhiều mấy ông
để kĩ là bấm vào đây xem chi tiết được
là ông ông đã để đẩy cái gì lên như thế
này truy vấn của ông có bao nhiêu câu
truy vấn ở đây đấy Bấm vào xem chi tiết
cụ thể truy vấn cũng có này Đấy thậm chí
là ông vừa thấy là người nào người làm
điều đấy này bao nhiêu Mua đồ được sử
dụng ở đây này mấy ông thấy rất rất
nhiều gà như tôi đã bảo hạn chế cái vụ
này Thôi cậu thấy tiếp theo là đã những
cái gì được cách này chẳng hạn thế
à tiếp theo là là có rất nhiều cái ở đây
ông ông Cái này là một cái Monitor tức
là có thể giám sát thì mấy ông thấy à Nó
có thể
nó luôn kiểu lưu lại mọi cái thứ xảy ra
trên trang của ông bao gồm kiểu như này
aception xong rồi job dùng các thứ even
xong rồi Nhiều cái nữa đấy cả log này
chẳng hạn Vân Vân rất rất nhiều cái đúng
không ạ Và vì nó rất rất nhiều cái và
tôi không không thích mấy cái đấy nó
luôn mà đấy thì tôi thường hay là tôi
sửa lại ở trong cái đấy tôi tắt bớt đi
Đấy nó sẽ như này Tắt bớt đi nó không
thấy nhiều rất nhiều
khác nó sẽ tê Scope này mình mặc định
lừa là tập Baek
nutify
Đôi khi về sau không biết được là mail
đã gửi hay chưa thì ông sẽ qua cái này
ông kiểm tra này
query
thì phải
nhớ nữa tôi sẽ tắt nó đi Xem bị lỗi nha
để ý gì nhất này
scandal
để kiểm tra nó chạy chưa Không cần view
View không cần luôn không cần view
gần như là tôi sẽ có request này vài cái
và cái này nó thường hay tự động nó sẽ
auto last ông thể để nó để mở lên
autolat kiểu này hoặc khi ông để mở
autolat này lên ông bấm lên request này
ông kiểm và ông cứ treo máy treo như này
để nó kiểm tra cho tôi nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ
tự động gọi Network cứ tầm 10 hay 5 giây
tự động gọi để lấy thêm dữ liệu sau
thú vị ví dụ lại cho Ông nhé
inbox lại phát nữa xử tội inbox lại phát
nữa này
giả sử như này mấy ông thấy là nó nó tự
động autolat nó load lại hộ cho tôi phát
nữa cậu thấy
sẽ nói luôn cả về log word
rất nhiều cái ngon rồi Nó kiểu để mình
giám sát những cái này rồi Thế có lock
Quốc thì nó sẽ điểm gì nó cũng để giám
sát nhưng mà cái này có một cái điểm rất
rất hay và tôi thấy là tôi thấy là kiểu
hình như mỗi thằng phải có cho ông xem
để mà in ra hoặc là để đi bốc để mà lưu
lại trong log thì thì cái ngon của nó là
như này nhất là cài thêm cái này
cái thêm cái này đúng nhỉ
Hồi đấy tôi có cái clear at Scope
hay là ông sẽ dùng câu lệnh là
tscope để xóa hết toàn bộ dữ liệu cho nó
nhẹ kiểu thế
tôi viết ở trong này tôi thường hay kia
tôi thường hay ghi nó là
tôi AC cũng là để clear kia nhưng mà để
thì nó tele scopeation
ông hình như là xóa trong
xóa không phải trong ngày hôm không phải
trong ngày hôm nay thì phải xoá có 8.000
thôi run này tôi không rõ được là đây
mặc định là lớn hơn 24 giờ đấy Kiểu như
thế cũng được rồi cũng được rồi nó sẽ hỗ
trợ xóa cho ông như con thằng blog này
thì nó hơi bị khó chịu một tí đó là đây
tra thử cái clear của Nga
thì giải pháp nó sẽ là
ác mà vẫn còn nguyên này Story nó vẫn
còn nguyên này trắng hỗ trợ gì việc xóa
rồi mà chạy mấy ông thấy Story nó vẫn
nhiều vãi chưởng này
tác dụng gì cả
Xem bấm bấm clear ở đây được không
liên tục kiểm tra của mình ạ Nó vẫn còn
ở đây nhớ Hồi đấy tôi dùng cái gì để xóa
ấy
xem lại phát link
lại mà Đúng không
mấy ông này bảo đã fix rồi tôi chưa thấy
có cái gì fix ở đây cả
vẫn chưa thấy thích gì cả
xóa dữ liệu đây
nhưng mà thôi không sao ờ
Thực ra là thỉnh thoảng mấy ông vào đấy
không Xóa tài được còn ở trên trên kia
đúng là hơi khó mà xóa
ông thầy nha ngoài việc là nó cũng lóc
lủng các thứ thứ cũng hiển thị âm mua đồ
đã chạy này câu truy vấn này Cách này
rất nhiều cái cái ngon ở đây là
này cái xịn nhất luôn Và tôi thấy cái xe
này này nó sẽ có hai kiểu một là
một là
một là ông Khi mà ông xe mặc định nó sẽ
luôn tạo một cái plapic Linh nghĩa là
bất kỳ ai có cái link này vẫn vẫn có thể
xem được trừ khi ông Ấn nút xóa đấy Kiểu
như thế
nha Nhưng mà cái này rất là nguy hiểm
nên là nên là khi mà ông Khi mà ông chạy
khi mà ông che Thì ông nên xe ít thông
tin nhạy cảm và lại cả ông hạn chế để
link
thêm một vài cái ở trong này nó cũng nó
cũng không phải là tất cả thông tin nhạy
cảm đấy nó chỉ đại khái như này mấy cái
này tôi nhớ không lầm là ông thể vào
config của nó để mở lên chẳng hạn nhưng
mà tôi không cần và tôi thường ấy Tôi
thường là tôi sẽ khi tôi chia sẻ tôi
thường hay chỉ chia sẻ pophome và
database
đầu tiên tôi thấy lỗi luôn đấy
đểu rồi
cái này là lỗi rồi
xem sao đây Để tôi cài chữ X nhé
quá
chả có cái gì cả
đây ngày lên chuyền toàn bộ thông tin
này lên cái trang này lỗi 500 lỗi 500
lỗi do server nhé Không phải lỗi cho tôi
nha đúng không
chắc là kiểu thỉnh thoảng nó bị gì đâu
không phải là là nó bị mãi đâu có gì mấy
ông cứ cài xong rồi xem thử lại sau cái
ngon nhất của nó cái xe đấy Xong rồi mấy
ông có thể mở ông có thể gửi cái link
đấy cho người khác có thể xem để xem
kiểu các thứ thứ tôi thường hay đi bất
kiểu thế tôi gửi cho sếp sếp xem cùng
tôi xem truy vấn như thế nào Vâng xịn ra
tiện
còn gì nhỉ
Mày thử coi cũng kiểu gần như là cũng
chưa code cái gì cả nãy giờ chị cứ ngồi
chia sẻ để xem tôi nghĩ code cái gì bây
giờ được nhỉ
tay vào code cái này lên cốt cái gì cơ
xem cốt bây giờ cái gì nhanh cơ
một tiếng rồi
hoàn thiện Tôi thấy cá nhân là Trang đến
a min mình có cái duyệt các thứ tương
đối hoàn thiện rồi
à Hôm trước tôi bảo là cái bình luận
comment mấy ông nhớ không ạ thì tôi đang
định bảo là mình sẽ có cái vụ là bình
luận ở đây tất cả mấy ông Đăng nhập đăng
ký xong ấy mày không phải đăng ký với tư
cách là ứng cử viên đúng không Thì thì
mình sẽ có mình sẽ đăng zin đang CV của
mình lên rồi các người khác chính hoặc
là chính tôi chính tôi vào ngồi
bình luận góp ý xem CV của ông nó đã ổn
hay chưa Mày không hiểu thì tôi không
đấy thì tôi tôi sẽ góp ý mấy về mấy cái
vụ đấy mày không hiểu không Nghĩa là là
để và người khác cũng có thể vào để mà
xem đánh giá để góp góp ý ở trong chính
mình trong cái CV của mấy ông ý tôi như
thế nghĩa mấy ông đăng lên không phải
đăng lên cho vui đúng không ạ Ngoài việc
là đăng lên để cho các nhà Tuyển dụng có
thể nhìn thấy thì cho chính người khác
cũng có thể vào để góp ý thì người ta
khuyên để thành nhà tôi chẳng hạn vào
khuyên các thứ trừ khi mà Mấy ông kiểu
bị sợ bị nhạy cảm quá như kiểu là
hoặc là không muốn công khai gì đó thì
chắc là
mình sẽ có cách sau
không à thường là đăng lên đây nên để
công khai còn nếu mấy ông thấy kiểu dạng
giả sử bị ném đá nhiều quá ông có thể
xóa đi không sao cả nếu mà ông xóa đi
rồi Ông đăng lại không sao cả
tôi nghĩ thế còn một khi ông đăng lên
đây là xác định nó lên công khai và ông
sẽ chấp nhận mọi ý kiến để để được góp ý
để được cái gì để cải thiện đúng không ạ
Mấy ông hiểu ý tôi không nó sẽ rất là
tốt rất là tốt theo kiểu
cái router riêng cho cái super amin Tôi
đang nghĩ thế Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ có
router cho
admin thôi là cùng lắm là mình về sau
mình
[âm nhạc]
chỉ xem được mỗi cái chóp là mỗi cái
post thôi còn
user hay những cái khác thì sẽ không
được nhìn thấy
được nhìn thấy cũng được chỉ vào xem
được post Ok
hành
Vietnamese
ấy ra
mình sẽ quay
không ạ như tôi từng bảo là nên tách dần
dần ra thằng mua đồ để xử lý nó hợp lý
hơn
lấy ô ô này
truyền lên là ô đấy Mình làm như này à
mình cứ mặc định là truyền lên như này
đúng không
có thể là là 1 hoặc là gì đó cho nó dễ
hiểu à Không nó ngắn ô thì nó sẽ dễ hiểu
hơn cũng được
sửa được cái đoạn o ấy
mình chuyển vô là không lên mà vẫn thấy
admin à Sai sai à đây em ti
à Rồi rồi không lên thì nó sai bởi vì
đây mình sẽ kiểm tra là
đợi tí
icess thì đoạn này tôi thấy đoạn này
không đúng lắm
râu là trống này
cô ở trong
này xem
à nó luôn luôn à thế dễ
kiểm tra ít luôn là được
dễ
kiểm tra nó không không null
Không tối ưu lắm nhìn trông hơi khó chịu
tí
xóa lại xóa hết đoạn đi nha
chọn này không có chọn này Ra hết không
chuyên lấy cái gì cả xin lỗi
còn nếu mà ông muốn yêu cầu là thậm chí
là khi Cái này là trống không không
truyền lên hẳn đấy luôn đấy thì
thì mình sẽ mình mình sẽ kiểu không
không Sắp mít nữa mình phải mình phải
Peter lại mấy cái này Đấy Tôi nghĩ là
kiểu này cho đơn giản đó
làm giao diện thôi
edit gì nhỉ Mình bỏ qua vụ edit đúng
không
Mình nên mặc định là lấy theo
mình đáng lẽ là mình phải mặc định là
mình sẽ phải lấy theo latit như thế này
nó chuẩn hơn này
được có trước thằng này à Buồn cười
toàn bộ Cái này
không thích điều hòa lắm
một tí về sau những cái code mới thôi
tôi sẽ tối ưu dần dần cho mấy ông
thị ra cái con trỏ có chịu
luôn luôn
kiểu tích vào là tất cả kiểu
hợp lý hơn
cũng có lá tía mà Vietnam
Mình gọi Ajax À đúng rồi mình gọi thông
tin bài
bảo sao
Đây là gì
kiểu Ajax các thứ thử mỗi tội là không
có sốt thôi
đến ăn mì cả bên này tương đối tương đối
rồi Peter các thứ được rồi nhỉ Tôi còn
Peter gì nhỉ Peter
à hình như mình chưa làm phí tới hết
Đúng rồi như mình chưa làm gì tới hết
thì phải
[âm nhạc]
bài đăng tôi vừa nãy tôi mới inbox lại
với tư cách là admin chứ không phải
Super amin thành ra nó biến thành chưa
tất cả bài chưa được duyệt ok Thế Thành
ra cậu
status bằng
không không có gì sai cả lỗi do người
dùng sai thôi người cốt sai máy tính
không hiện ra
mình có post nó cái hơi khó chịu là nếu
mà mình lưu lại là kiểu Y5 này đôi khi
mình quên xử lý 5 nó là gì Kiểu như này
mình mình lại phải vào trong i5 để kiểm
tra lại
Xem thực sự là cái nào mới là cái đúng
ok rồi ra kết quả rồi
một bài là Kim mình sẽ
nhiều này có muốn
đi bài này
nó một bài nhiều sẽ được ghi mà chẳng
hạn thế đúng không ạ
xong rồi tôi sẽ Tôi muốn lọc rất nhiều
cái hôm trước mới chỉ đọc theo cái
đọc theo cái này ở
hơi khó chịu ở đây đó là mình nên hiển
thị ra cái label cho cái lọc nó ổn hơn
phải
đổi đời phone
mà
là được
Nó không làm gì
Peter này bộ
nữa
chưa để dạng Nó là tiếng kiểu dạng đa
ngôn ngữ Cái len cho về sau vẫn phải sửa
lại nữa Mày thật
thông qua từ đây
ấy nhỉ
cái part time nha
lại trong dictionary nó sẽ không bao lỗi
nữa
như này là được
nó sẽ được tích sẵn và đây mình sẽ
chuyên compassan là một lên để mình bỏ
tích vào đi Này không chuyển nó lên luôn
đấy Thì bây giờ mình sẽ truyền thêm cái
part time này vào trong
Peter ở đây
sẽ là
sau đó tôi kiểm tra thêm ở đây nếu là
thì tôi sẽ
thôi nhé
kệ này đi qua mình kệ này ở number King
này thì ra tôi vẫn đang phân vân về cái
vụ này chắc là cứ tạm để đấy đã ở hết xử
cái để mà Peter đấy chỉ có mỗi cái này
thôi mà đi mua Apple với cái gì đó này
thôi mặc định được tích hết rồi
city chồng nữa này
cách có vẻ CT trống ở đây nó đang bị
thêm vào sao đây City ở đâu vẫn có
trường hợp trống rồi nhỉ Với lại
có trường hợp nó chống được thật
nếu không làm
em ti lại tiếp tục bỏ qua tiếp
nó mới chuẩn đấy
bây giờ bởi vì nó có cách rồi mình cách
nó rồi nên thành ra mình vẫn đang lấy cạ
nó ra tôi sẽ thử clear cách như này cách
này
nó sẽ chỉ lấy ra đúng cái kiểu chuẩn hơn
mình clear cách rồi mà ok
và có cả bình dương Chứng tỏ hôm trước
tôi inbox file khác
Chắc là chỉ thế này nhỉ Thế này thôi
mỗi vụ ảnh của cái thằng này sai kệ đi
Đúng rồi quên mất một cái hôm trước mình
Phi tô vài cái ở đây sao mình search như
thế này thứ nhất là mất luôn cả cái page
của mình
giả sử là tôi reset lại
filter nhé
show à
Có một thằng nó chỉ chứa Thiếu cái post
truyền vào
OK OK để xem Tại sao thằng nào chuyển
thiếu hay ra cái lỗi Mới
test rồi ra lỗi mới kiểu này cũng được
mình sẽ ghét ở đây này
rồi Hình như hôm trước cũng lại ngồi sửa
code code đoạn này
mình đi đè cái select
giả sử như này mấy ông thấy
thực ra Quy Nhơn có nhiều
mất đúng không ạ mất thì mình bản chất ở
đây mình sẽ cần là phải truyền thêm vào
cái cái Peter vào trong cái
khi mà nhảy sạp backginate đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ
cái filter sang để tôi thử xem nhé
gọi request Nhanh
flow này của tôi cái gì luôn
[âm nhạc]
rồi mình khi mà mình filter cái này mình
cũng cần phải truyền lên cái page mình
nói hàng ngày nữa
phải này thì search mình sẽ có một cái
input
mặc định lúc đầu sẽ là một chẳng hạn
page ở đây là
ghét này mặc định nó là một này đây sẽ
là Tết
tại trang này
tôi thử Xóa hết toàn bộ thằng này đi
đúng không ạ Lúc đầu trang trắng tinh
đúng không ạ
bằng 1 luôn như này chuẩn rồi
tôi sang page 4 này
tôi truyền Đà Nẵng
sẽ
Ờ
may trường hợp này Tắt bớt cái này đi
Cần Thơ chẳng hạn thì bị mất phết à
Tết mùng 1
pass sang đâu
sửa thì cũng là một cách khác đấy Em
thấy không em vừa sửa sẽ là kiểu
chèn thêm theo kiểu ở bên này bên
này là admin user À
đúng rồi thì có thể chèn ở bên
Phan An cũng được không cần phải bên bác
em kiểu này hai cách chèn đúng không
và và sửa cái này như anh bảo thì anh
vừa kiểm tra được Excel đỡ phải chuyển ô
cái này đúng nhưng mà filter thì mình
nên chuyển thêm cả cái
Giờ này
kiểm tra rô kiểm tra
bỏ qua cái chắc phải đi clai cái này rồi
bởi vì bây giờ cốt cốt này nó không còn
là cốt mới à không phải con cốt
này ở cái
packinate của mình cũng đang bị sai
bị thiếu mình sẽ phải apen cả cái
request Nếu mà truyền lên à Đúng rồi
Mình còn chẳng làm Peter gì cả nãy mình
phải làm Peter đoạn này mới đúng nữa
Nói chung là buổi hôm nay tôi mục đích
của tôi cũng nhẹ nhàng thôi đó chia sẻ
rất nhiều rất nhiều tool các thứ các bạn
làm quen các thứ chứ cũng không Đây là
cũng gần như là trang web này cũng tương
đối xong rồi đấy cũng
chỉ còn sửa lại về giao diện là chủ yếu
thôi giao diện cái này cho mình xong rồi
Chắc là để buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ đây tôi
sẽ Note lại 4 sau tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông về
địt lòi code lên thì nó sẽ là như thế
nào được không ạ
thôi mấy ông còn thắc mắc gì Những không
nhỉ
thì mình phải từ Avatar của người
đi sai sai ở đây
Domino đúng không
top 3 chứ nhỉ
xinh vẫn khẳng định vẫn xinh
này
à không không về tôi nhớ không phải để
nutify ở đây mà tôi sẽ để là là về sau
tôi sẽ làm theo kiểu là tôi sẽ chơi trò
lưu lại lịch sử rất là hay là tôi sẽ
biểu diễn mấy ông xem
tôi sẽ ghi lại đây nhé hồi trước tôi
chơi cái trò đấy
là
trên log
nó sẽ hiển thị ra trên đó là cái trang
web này đã lên phiên bản thử bao nhiêu
rồi và đã thêm những cái tính năng gì
hay Hạnh đấy tôi sẽ hiển thị ra ở đây hỗ
trợ tôi từng làm vụ đấy tôi như tôi chia
sẻ mấy ông rồi từng làm vụ bên dkm
như thế nào
thị ở trên đó ở đây này bởi vì trên máy
của tôi thì cái file Excel đấy nó chưa
nó nó không có chứ không Hồi đấy tôi đọc
từ cái file Excel Đấy là cách một cách
thôi tôi có thể làm được nhiều cách khác
để để một cái trên đó là
cập cập nhật lần nhất là ngày thứ bao
nhiêu đã cập nhật thêm những cái gì cái
vẻ hay mà Đấy
thôi buổi mai chắc là thế thôi
thắc mắc cần chữa gì đó thì cứ
cứ chuẩn bị sẵn an tâm lý nhé để buổi
sau để bữa sau hỏi đáp tôi chữa luôn nhé
bây giờ mấy ông nha
[âm nhạc]